90 seconds or something here we go cube
fanatics are you nervous watching
I'm nervous playing here we go Oh what
did I tell you out of nowhere
okay there's about 115 players average
rating almost 1,800 it's guy in a move
oh I might get a quick resigner 15
seconds you got to move within 1500
double the points give me the win come
on 15 seconds is up
are you kidding me what's going on this
game isn't even starting it should be 15
seconds and I get the W give me the W
they're not giving me the W let me pre
move let me see who has a win already
look it people have three lucky very
lucky
20 seconds what's going on man my screen
is fine
there's no it's not a Comcast game but
I'm seeing that out of the corner of my
eye okay the game states have been
doubled so I will get credit for I
should be getting two points here what a
start what a start
boom back to tournament who has two who
has three okay three a bunch of twos and
somebody with some cool shades right
here
Oh No
wow what a start no game for the first
one this one doesn't boot up whoa is
this intense look it's okay what do you
do you do some homework when that
happens you don't stare to kid with
glasses
let's see confuse ray is my game
starting it's starting it's starting
it's here ah
as soon as I turn away it starts
said a sneak attack I was I was hoping
for just an air and then points that
would have been ideal looking for the
those ideal wins okay back up I'm gonna
target this guy hopefully d6 give me d6
going for a tricky stuff man
tricky stuff and get that night out of
here soon he's got no business being
there actually he could sit there I'm
not afraid of him should I be
I shouldn't be if pawn push don't know
I'll just take here just come over here
he'll he'll get away whenever I want
like right now now I wanted to be kicked
away I couldn't take like this cuz the
knight grabs here okay we're gonna have
Bishop takes Knight takes I'm up a piece
I got to watch out for pawn push they
might try a sneak attack that's a sneak
attack it's not there yet okay Knight
takes it's got main you want to take the
knight power of suggestion give me this
move Knight oh oh no no it's okay it's
still okay I'm have this covered I'm on
the Queen there's no oh they can take
here okay we're gonna have that aren't
we I have passed pawns time is even
things should be okay no no oh I almost
just fell for mate what stuff fall for
me
don't fall for me Oh rook f1 um like
right now let's get a flight square out
tempting come on who else would have
done that raise your hand how many of
you would have pushed that pun it's okay
to admit it however is the clock all I
ever have is the clock time burner City
that's all I ever had of pawn push a
couple times no no no keep that rook
around back to tournament four leaders
leaders leaders somebody has eight
I'm in 12th ooh double those points
Sicilian I need to land a fishing pole
Age 2 where are you at where are you at
age to save the day that Bishop out of
there he's got no business right here I
kick them around okay one step closer
here
d4 take a couple times Castle kingside
you know you want to get my bishop on
this diagonal I'm not afraid of losing
my knight I could maybe get dark square
weaknesses dark square weaknesses dark
square weaknesses pawn push if the Queen
goes on this diagonal pawn push Bishop
h6 maybe rook to g8 rook g8 right now
maybe something against this square
light square weaknesses let's open up
this diagonal okay that's a that's that
was an on purpose that wasn't on purpose
Knight takes Knight here let's just do
that
get my Bishop out doing some Bishop here
why didn't I do that sooner what am i
doing let's try this again I don't even
do I even have anything
rook I want both my rook on G and a rook
on H the knight moves Knight here is
deadly absolutely deadly word blocked up
with time what my opponent is going into
a giant think tank a giant think tank
Bishop check could grab this pawn I
don't know if I want to though I feel
like I should be smashing through on
this square why is my opponent I'm
moving they're cheering up a lot of time
breathe city this is breathe city I have
trouble breathing sometimes let me just
do this no matter what the game is not
gonna finish okay clock is oh don't
check the server come on you know it's
out oh my goodness okay there we go back
to terminal sixteen twelve twelve twelve
a bunch of 12s I'm in 10th tenth
okay a lot of time 24 minutes the French
oh I thought d5 was gonna be played okay
maybe I should have just reinforced that
square that pawn instead of capturing
this bishop is I'm not afraid of that
this will be a pawn sack upon sack and
then get some pressure on the efj off
the pawn moves I can always take it I'm
taking it
rook e1 I have an attack brewing attack
is not far off discovered tricks Knight
moving to g6
what is this cleanup - bishop here rook
here all candidate moves capture with my
rook because I'm hitting the clean
bishop check right here is gonna be
brutal or it's not coming with a check
but it's coming with the deadly pin this
might be game over a resigned time I
have an edge on time they're gonna milk
this they're gonna milk the clock oh is
that what we're gonna see he's still
pinned rook takes Queen takes is
available keep pieces pinned
not afraid of that either I think I
could smash through here a couple of
times the Queen is pinned Queen is
pinned and then that's me
okay back to chairman I almost miss that
he's four 20s and an 18 here we go 22
minutes remaining
how is it gonna finish there's a lot
there's a giant pack up here there's a
hundred and thirty three players here we
go
all right let's go here okay I feel like
I played this guy once already
um all right no I mean it was like a
reason to foul all right so I remember
seeing this name keep my queen on this
dog and oh they missed that they thought
I was gonna take with my queen I guess
inside cap King side Castle Knight here
is deadly it's deadly pawn push I could
take this bishop at the very least h2 is
on you got to play
six Tong push she dropped the bishop g3
are they gonna do this it's very common
no H - how many times each - no okay yes
I thought that that was like a buy a
shirt click that wasn't buy this shirt
that was add to friends which is quite
alright smoking hot
this guy is smoking hot here 615 38 ok
get my bishop here push this night away
okay I should have maybe done man okay
Queen I'm not afraid of that my nights
gonna reroute here and now there's light
square weaknesses f5 after I Castle f5
make Queen over here f5 is coming up
soon right now where this is weak um
okay I'm getting I'm getting material
I'm getting material here my night out
to h5 no matter what I believe
and then my queen out to g3 why what is
my opponent thinking about the thinking
about its blocking with the rook okay
I guess the knight coming here is going
to be a good idea because I end up
having to take I want my queen out here
on that night Queen can't go too far
and if it's threatened what do I do
probably here no I want to keep it on
this diagonal there might be some sack
against this since I controlled GA let
me back up all the way I like my bishop
better than this one if this can't be
broken down then this bishop is kind of
out of play
alright let me stop no I should that
should have been okay pawn push I could
have always played a c4 now I'd have to
worry about that Bishop takes pawn is
available but I don't know if they're
gonna do that I could grab excuse me I
could grab this pawn on D
let's go for it I'm on the bishop as
well this move was played I guess to get
this c4 advanced in but I don't know if
it's really working out I guess I guess
it could still work this this structure
gave me smashed open my bishop is very
active right now my opponent is down on
time I didn't even realize back
determinate 40 30s I have a lead ten
point lead
okay c5 no matter what okay this is like
the anti fishing pole set up going with
that but what is this light square
weaknesses my opponent might not be able
to castle they're not able to castle huh
no night here is a you can do night
there but not you can't my pond is
controlling this I want to keep this
right how it is I don't want this bishop
to see night here making a lot of pawn
loops my bishop is very annoying night
here can't move that night just yet oh
but you could take that Oh Mikey Castle
get castle there and then Knight right
here I guess I do this and then get my
knight right here my bishop my rook
right here okay I got to be very
cautious of what oh man
I don't want to what my knight the Coons
gonna get right there I feel like I'm
gonna be something Bad's gonna happen I
see bad things happening fast bad things
are gonna happen fast to feel it 17
seconds I don't have any time can my
knight get a check here please Mike I
want a queen trade darn it I can't get a
Queen trade where's that Queen trade
when you need it where is it Knight
takes years available I got to get rid
of that tricky night he is way too
dangerous way too dangerous that is
still available
I think this pawn could have fallen like
a bunch of times already
oh no why'd I do that I'm getting made
it oh man why'd I do that back to
tournament back to tournament I dropped
back wasn't a lead I dropped that and
it's done oh man why did I move my King
like that I was down on time too I'm
gonna blame it on the clock
we blame that one on the clock sometimes
my best friend and then when it's not
going well I just blame the clock I'm on
the bishop
don't you dare count me out who knew
that was who knew that line was coming
yeah it's about that time it's about
that time when he loses and says yeah
don't come you know
he is Bishop takes Knight for guru skis
here we go
I think there's some tricky stuff over
here though I might have to take the
bishop oh please take that oh I'm in a
nasty pen no I'm not I was in a
potential pin okay I just take this Wow
okay can I get a check over here I just
got a look at the clock that's all I
ever have the clock let me just do this
no matter what there we go
I came with interest grab a pun Oh Adobe
Flash land that was almost an Adobe
Flash rook here just take I got back
rakers big trouble back ranks back
rankers they wouldn't take that would
they time is an issue I could come back
from this can I I had a lead you have to
give up the Queen the Queen has to block
queeny's dead gotta go here no time back
to tournament 472 oh man oh this guy if
I have to get paired up against him my
clock is gonna run out fast I have to
try and confuse this guy let's see we're
bad jokes who knows about that the last
time I tried to crack a joke I got
scholars mating try to be cute with the
an x squared line yeah you got squared
we got the last laugh Wow French defense
this always leads to a fast win my
bishop has seen better days look at him
he's happy Happy's piece around alert
right here on b7 c4 though he could
spring to life in a heartbeat you'll
have to believe me here you
he's breathing down whites position they
rid of this night and then post up on
this light square I was ready to take
with my queen how bad would that have
been very bad is the answer to that one
okay I can take this no I can Oh what am
i doing can I get this bishop hopefully
yes oh yeah this is not good this is not
good
I'm dropping stuff everywhere I look
there's tricky Forks around every corner
what is he up to just give up on give up
a pond pin the night if he goes here
everybody loves pins I can't do this cuz
of tricky Forks let's push this keep
pushing him okay this is working let's
just defend stuff now let's just defend
with check hit a rook hit that rook
let's back up
when in doubt back up that's a fantastic
idea right there
get behind the pass pawn is another idea
grab pawns give checks time burners time
burner time clocks are finally even 4x
how many times did I miss that
where's the mate watch out for stalemate
there's no stalemates are there I had me
a lot sooner
that's me finally back determined 110
what is this guy eating 110 72 and then
I have 68 Celine 86 the guy who gave me
a beating in the in the Simon that we
did this guy gave me a beating he made a
really strong move and I had nothing I
remember that do you remember that I
remember the things that are painful and
that was painful
okay pin this night me tried to bring
the pain to my opponent okay that nights
in a pen he's still in a pen I want to
hit him again
attack pin pieces is the plan that's the
plan more attacking
of the pinned pieces it could be a
problem fast very fast this Bishop is
sectioned off to the Queen side
therefore the King side dark squares
could be a problem
and they are a problem and this is a
problem - I'm grabbing this pawn if the
rook moves it's a mate until Oh
this is a problem Queen h5 maybe I don't
even take the rook I'm not gonna take
the rook
there's something here there's got to be
something good here
rook here it's just made I move the
bishop oh what's the save here is there
even a save they resign back to
tournament 86 130 130 I wouldn't even be
caught up if I didn't lose that game
Brent I still wouldn't be caught up even
if I'm if I had a squeaky-clean
performance up to this point okay I got
a challenge these pawns soon still
challenge when the Knights pin I'm
grabbing this I'm just I want to go here
get in there take the dark square bishop
and then put pressure on this could take
because it would come with check
sometimes there's the tactic of uh of
what okay get my rook here I don't know
what I'm trying to say castle here is
this pawn gonna push probably could let
me stop this maybe I want to do this
push just take this night I got a play
over here otherwise I'm gonna get
squeezed somehow hunt eggs okay now that
tension should be over in this direction
I want to trade light square bishop so I
want to focus on this grind I'm also on
c3 right now Knight c4 stuff and then
maybe get my Bishop on this diagonal
it's gonna be a good spot pawn push if
the rooks double and then hollow that's
good move okay let's see if pawn push
happens here yes it's happening
okay Knight here the knight is kind of
pinned and pawn push what's that night
doing the night can maybe take here
Queen trade my favorite my favorite
Queen trade
and a backup how do I get rid of that
night what a beast
what a beast get out of tricky stuff
this guy's flying and oh that's a fork
in it half I'm dropping my queen oh man
and he's coming back there's more Forks
Wow this night is so dangerous I'm
dropping everything oh no oh no I am so
dead I am so dead
I gotta run over here and stuff look at
these ponds oh my goodness I'm dropping
everything oh I have nothing nothing
should I even be playing on where the
stalemates
is their stalemate around stalemate is
there still me that's gonna be made over
here no no no no what do I got it's a
draw oh it's true oh how many points was
that can we get a tally I can't breathe
I'm dropping a pond that's what's
happening this guy's gonna kill me he's
the killer he's a killer guy felt way
too strong that guy felt way too strong
man what am I even doing I'm very dizzy
right now I've two nights I have the
night pair okay I meet focus here can I
focus for once touched off my queen okay
let's trade Queens okay let me get
tripled pawns
everybody loves triple pawns and now get
my rook active let's do this double or a
let's double check yeah let's double
check double check
okay rook check pawn push triple pawns I
guess that pounds gonna push
my rook wants to go into pacman mode
you're just gonna have to believe me
okay let me get this guy he's a number
one priority rook is trapped if it goes
here it's a dead duck he's not going
there my rook is gonna go here my king
is gonna go after this pond I think yes
he is that's what he wants to do okay I
have stuff glued together take like this
and my beep on remains past I have a
time edge thankfully my pond is still
past I could keep rolling here keep
going he's passed and he's fast
remember that past ponds are fast ponds
here we go keep pushing everything's
glued together on the Kings side my
opponent is also down down time more
checks I could just avoid them I could
keep making progress more progress keep
pushing that past pond there down on
time back to terminal 171 31 30 I'm
looking for a second whoa
how much time seven minutes only two
losses uh there no not allies a loss and
a draw felt like two losses okay be file
can we get a B file here I should have
made me taken there let's get a center
and get a center Forks everybody loves a
fork a bishop or Knight is going to die
my opponent gets to decide which it's
the bishop but now this is gonna be the
night soon trouble oh my queen to take
up a nice post right here
the knight is dead drop the bishop back
or not let me go here that's a great
comment right there let me go here we go
right here let's just come back home
sometimes it's okay to go home the
knight is pinned I might want to just
take him very soon Knight here to here
okay that's not happening let me just
get rid of that tricky night and before
this pawn causes me any problems when
you just push this guy forward and now I
can rely upon the white squares
I want to function on the light squares
I also want a clean trade as usual
bishop here get out of pins
get out of scary pins Bishop here watch
out for Mouse lips and stuff I said hit
this clean look here look here pawn push
I guess and then King up to H very Oh
what's happening I thought that came
with a threat
rook h6 o that pod comes with the threat
right there okay this is it should be
quite all right
a lot of material if it's taken I don't
take back because it's pinned I should
have attacked it though doesn't matter I
have a ton of material it's still pinned
it's still pinned I'll take it next no
matter what then again and then push the
pawn and then push the Queen where's the
main make it one two three no matter
what back to tournament 128 190 150 150
can I get top three that's what I'm
fishing for this guy it's off the hook
look at him 14 out of 14 here we go
Nikolas he has given me a beating and a
half a couple times let's come over are
you kidding me I'd this happened before
against him oh nice so hook came back in
that game are you kidding me this is
deja vu
oh I have to somehow do something
miraculous again I need time burners in
every position time burners okay keep it
close my bishop on the light squares is
a stupid stupid piece I'll take him
though my Kings gonna run over here I
have light square control somehow
come on function on light squares
light squares tricky Knights I get my
king over here oh oh oh we're not gonna
go I also had to do like an eenie meenie
miney mo right there an eenie meenie
miney mo technique oh man this is gonna
be dangerous can I run over here not
really don't give a check come on can I
save it over here my Knights need to do
something else
where's a four
can I get it let's open it up over here
can I get made somehow I have that
covered that spot is past
where's they're looking ago that's a
passed pawn am I getting this I'm out
check where's the tricky stuff can I get
here Can I grab that pawn first I'm
somehow defending I got this pawn we're
still somehow defending I might be
better all of a sudden I might be better
I think I'm better oh man I have the two
rooks now surprisingly this is now
better for me somehow the time is also
even what happened here I have to watch
that Bishop g4 move it's getting the
best of me every time every time let's
just drop the rook
let's not drop the rook let's watch out
for my time also okay
get here and then here was that even
gonna be Czech pawn push they don't
they're down a time back to tournament
oh my goodness two thirty one seventy
one seventy one fifty one forty six I
need to get to 170 okay gotta play
against the Godfather's the last guy you
want to see that a win you need a quick
win you have to play The Godfather man
he got the Godfather right this guy is
negative 14 is he is he uh the time
burner stay tuned there that is not the
last bad joke you'll hear that is not
the last bad joke come on give me a
fishing pole and then I need a
buzzer-beater at the end
I need a buzzer-beater ok h2 is I'm
gonna rise in h2 is on the horizon h2
where are you at don't play g3 whatever
you do don't play g3 don't do it yes h2
exactly what I needed
o2 3191 71 66 I have time to get him one
more I gotta play against Wanderlei is
this Wanderlei
Oh from godfather to Wanderlei Silva you
gotta play again Silva right now man
this guy will give me a beating in a
blink in a blink we get the dark squares
where are you at d6 hit the bishop
bad things happen get on the dark
squares my opponents defending they're
gonna push my knight away but he's going
to a good square he's really happy about
that Square gonna have to believe me c5
is beautiful let's keep him there that's
what I'm getting at stop this Knight
he's gonna challenge my knight that's
okay though no he can't
I got I've grabbed the bishop now I want
to hit the Queen I'm hitting the Queen
probably just push my pawn to f5 and
then I just I better go quick this still
knife is not finished a minute 30 I'm in
at 30 okay give me this pawn get rid of
it and they kick the night away somehow
I can't do that so easily let me open up
the G file okay my ponies kind of
floundering they're not sure what to do
and I'm not sure what to do either
it happens sometimes that happens
sometimes you just don't know what to do
20 seconds remaining a minute 9 a minute
8 ok open up the G file is the next idea
here it's the next idea am i doing okay
I have everything seal let me get rid of
the dark square Bishop that's the plan
get rid of that dark square Bishop I
want the G file to open up - I didn't do
this just for fun I promise I didn't do
that just for fun I have something in
mind with that I also want to drop back
and then made on aged 7 8 main - threat
1 - just move anything they're down at
I'm also back to turn of 186 I need a
quick win 30 seconds remaining I'm 14
second hour 14 minutes out this guy is
gonna bring the pain here 99 pain 99 is
not gonna resign Oh what is that that's
a free pun what they resign Noah thanks
for playing fourth and no confetti oh
man
ah what a rollercoaster game I should
have had 2 losses
I'm lucky to even get in fourth place
good games oh wow
Dylan Dylan ended up in first I'll write
Dylan 2009 beating out Alva who's a good
player maybe they got paired up I wonder
if you guys played awesome